game
percent showing off the handles reverse
finishes over whipping Yama scoot
Henderson he's been the star tonight so
far tonight take a look at scoop
Henderson what he does
the Finish though going around the 7-4
when the Yama to be able to finish off
the glass the body control
and the night Defenders when he raises
up the shoe Corey that's not fair it
isn't that's not fair I like this
matchup on Anderson one-on-one yeah
right back Adam
cards getting the job done in scoop
Anything You Can Do I can do
scoot still looking to get it going
finds John Jenkins always a good idea
what all the way
on the take Henderson oh my goodness
scoot Henderson PC are you kidding scoot
Henderson is for on hunts three is Off
the Mark that was Sensational hits the
number two projected NBA draft in the
2023 draft and play I loved his
awareness to dump down to Mecca
we fell hard
and here's the steal ignite with a
Chance Henderson at the hole Yeah
Henderson to the rescue rescue talk
about you know Jonathan Williams there
are rookies on the other side of the
floor as well scoot Henderson with the
takeaway two on two go oh
scoot Henderson we have some exciting
things we want to do this year okay here
we go here we go
heart made it halftime have been
impressive
Henderson driving Baseline Up and Under
hello he just buys man carton nice
little scoop past it inside Leonard
six seconds to go Henderson turns the
corner got it to go and the foul what a
play by scoot Henderson Henderson
pull-up jumper short King again
offensive rebound back to school oh baby
it was kind of clear it so they can't
switch it got the clear out against
Pacheco scoot Henderson abs
amazing defensively and offensively
under five to go here comes dude
Henderson all alone it's showtime
yes
[Music]
yes they're gonna work through Henderson
scoop what's the honor attention to go
does it ignite the teams who come and
play they know that too so they're
trying to give ignite their best shot
nice scoop shot underneath and Henderson
keeping it alive
goes hard to the bucket and if it's not
there I'd like to see that ball move the
other side Oh that's oh a rim attack by
scoot Henderson